welcome to this video this is Grand
Master Eric Hanson Eric Hansen from
Canada they have not played them yet on
the ISS see I think I played a couple of
bullet game as years ago on CH s cube
but never here okays playing the delayed
exchange variation of the reuleaux pass
it's um that's a very solid choice for
white black has no particular problems
but it's not very exciting for the most
part and I can take a five but i'm not
sure if this is the right decision
i'm not sure but i guess shouldn't spend
the whole day on this decision
its ideas soup to occupy a forum 25
maybe fighting fighting for the square I
probably should have gone to d5 anyway
okay at least is not getting a piece
reform as far as I can see now this this
makes use of the fact that the deep aunt
has to protect the night on c4 looks
quite okay for black be very surprising
if white had anything here
I'm threatening to take on d3 just with
an advantage the five pawn is also a
liability I don't know maybe I'm you
know in a good situation here
don't know what you should do yeah maybe
maybe really this Andrew q1 but this is
very unassuming oh look there ok so he
just gives me the better the better game
here let's say he accepts that black is
justice better I wonder any tactic and
nothing huge quindi for for the cheap
queen takes f to trick that's a really
cheap trick ok I just keep a 5 covered
it wasn't hanging but it probably will
at some point maybe really this move it
I know it's a very cheap trick but
Quincy 3 can also be an idea now now
that he has moved the beep on ok he saw
the trick which was to be expected just
just centralized he still cannot take on
c6 due to Queen f2
check
John got the e-file that shouldn't be
bad twin c6 Queen F to stir rather
embarrassing and well I don't know what
he's doing next okay this one mmm quindi
five he has Queen f4 I see it's not so
easy for me to really get some
substantial progress in how do I regroup
him Queen d7 maybe now he's threatening
to take here but okay I can do this and
on Queen FYI can play rookie 7 just
covering system now that's a good mood
should have played that quicker trading
us out of the question this end game is
terrible he has to play Queen afore i
guess or maybe queen h5 but that runs
into g6
it's not very nice this position
okay so i can take root a 2d for this is
this idea but then Bishop to b4 for
Rupert III outside really dominating
possession it would have been dominating
but I forgot this I forgot about this
move now that's bad okay it's still good
for black but I should have considered
that okay for now take know it takes is
a tempo so I just I can improve the King
first here are two H you probably hear
so taking it it's not helping maybe I
can really get the King more involved
takes Bishop takes is nice for pressure
against f2 so okay still cannot take I
could play c4 actually that's not bad
now that my king is on d6 I'm angling
form like Bishop see 30 it's a counter
play maybe Nyjah for I want to prevent
takes
this still should be excellent time
morning eyes got to check hmm ships III
is what I wanted to play Knight takes
rook takes d4 what he's got 94 check
that's irritating ok so I'm going back
back to cover and now my rook has no
squares oh come on this is this is
crazier what am I doing here I can go
here and then like completely after
completely out playing him I'm screwing
this up right great ah how stupid can
you play really that this is just so
stupid what I'm doing him Oh frustrating
he really are no come on check
17 seconds dad it's entirely unnecessary
what a stupid game what a stupid game
how did I bangle that up yeah that was
that was such an easy will in the end
game yeah we were not time anyway I know
you can take your time now check
position is still nothing provide
probably and he will be winning on time
no no way is turning that on position
here okay we're not dying for effects on
time how can I actually wrap this up
this is just lost for white nothing more
nothing less so let's have a look this
this shouldn't be bad yeah approaching
here with the king and it shouldn't be
bad ready so look to you one c4 yeah and
this is just over what what am I doing
here age five yeah it's this is losing
time you know maybe it's dueling time
this is this is just over am attacking a
for checking d for auntie resigns yeah
this is this is useless now I'm just uh
I just wanted to play it safe by okay
it's also winning of course that's not
not the point but it makes it more
tricky what I wanted to do is I took now
which is a mistake I wanted to
originally play this but after here I
cannot take a joke because of this this
check and well this is not what I want
so I came into some some difficult to
see em yeah c5 still wins according to
the comp but well this is this is
approaching really tricky territory
yeah I mean I'm winning this pawn and
wins but this is not easy at all so I
cannot really blame myself there but
here at bishop's III it's like I mean
super easier this this something and and
over the problem was that he he really
was in trouble already when he when he
played the Queen over to f3 after he
formed Black is just better that's a
typical central Blake here and he will
be settled with some sort of weakness
and Joe check I'm in here this is just a
terribly bad end game and it's a it's a
it's a matter of taste what I'm doing a
bishop before it's also better for black
but this was good i think it just keeps
controller and here here c5 yeah this
was okay i'm totally satisfied the way I
played this he was just completely
outplayed but I'm an idiot yeah but
whatever can I say taking on g4 is
really stupid I mean even then of course
black is clearly better even hear
clearly better but I'm into I'm into
this I mean two issues now it's
difficult I have 30 seconds so ah yeah
okay thanks for watching